yesterday I told you about the push
towards war with Iran that's being
orchestrated by the Trump administration
and of course it's being done with the a
very eager assistance of the very war
hungry national security advisor john
bolton who's actually been trying to go
with iran since he was in the George W
Bush administration unfortunately
however British intelligence is now
directly undermining Donald Trump's
narrative pointing out that there simply
is no increasing threat from Iran and
that in fact the majority of the
aggression currently in the u.s. Iran
faceoff is coming from the American side
from the Trump administration not from
Iran and sadly I've got to do my
necessary disclaimers I am NOT Pro Iran
in the sense that I do believe that Iran
is in many ways a bad faith actor I
don't want Iran to have nuclear weapons
I do believe that the world is less safe
if Iran has nuclear weapons but I also
exist in the real world and I'm not
going to make things up and Iran is not
the one making misstep after misstep in
the last year remember that Barack Obama
signed the Iran nuclear deal and Iran
stuck to that deal and in comes donald
trump and says we're voiding the deal
period trump then goes even further and
says you know i think we're gonna do
some more sanctions on iran so iran has
reacted to this unprovoked aggression by
the united states by saying okay if
you're voiding our deal and you're
sanctioning us then we'll resume some
nuclear development i mean why not and
immediately the Trump administration has
started to use that to push for war
Trump has been presented with a plan to
send a hundred and twenty thousand
troops to the region by the way does he
need congressional approval for that
because when it was Obama deciding about
military mobilization Trump regularly
tweeted that the president needs to get
congressional approval for that that's a
question which we may have to explore in
more detail very soon
Trump foments the aggressive rhetoric
and it is starting to smell like Iraq
it's starting to look and sound like the
lead up to the Iraq war but then in
comes British intelligence yesterday our
ally and
says there's no increased threat from
Iran in Syria there's no increased
threat from Iran in Iraq which directly
contradicts what the Trump
administration has been touting and
repeating and this is coming from the
top British general in the United
states-led coalition against Isis and
this is key because this is the claim
that's made by the Trump administration
to start setting up an increased
military presence in the region that
Iranian backed forces are more and more
of a threat in the region and
immediately after this top top British
intelligent US Central Command says now
no British intelligence is just wrong
once again putting Trump's opinion in
direct conflict with the intelligence of
our allies and sometimes of our own
intelligence agencies quite frankly
here's a quote from Major General
General Christopher jika who said no
there has been no increased threat from
Iranian backed forces in Iraq and Syria
we're aware of that presence clearly and
we monitor them along with a whole range
of others because that's the environment
we're in we are monitoring the Shia
militia groups I think you're referring
to carefully and if the threat level
seems to go up then we'll raise our
force protection measures accordingly
Trump immediately dismissing this as
fake news lovely right and immediately
this is starting to take shape and it's
looking a lot like that free Iraq war
period during the George W Bush
administration the difference being that
hopefully this time there will be more
prominent elected officials who will be
loudly against it Bernie Sanders for
example already tweeting quote the
United States Congress must do
everything it can to prevent the Trump
administration's attempts to put us on
the brink of a catastrophic and
unconstitutional war with Iran senator
Elizabeth Warren also tweeting quote we
cannot let the Trump administration drag
us into yet another war in the Middle
East this is exactly why the president
doesn't have the constitutional
authority to declare war that's
Congress's job and that's why I'm
supporting this legislation to prevent a
war with Iran understand Trump is trying
to start a war and one of our biggest
allies Britain is not on our side on the
basis for that war and is in total
disagreement about who the aggressor is
okay our ally the UK says we are the bad
actor here we're the aggressor and sadly
we are now there is one upside here as
bad of a player as the Iranian regime
has been there are more and more reports
that they actually see through the
bluster from Trump and recognize this as
goading from Trump and a deliberate
provocation and hopefully they're smart
enough not to take the bait I do not
support the Iranian regime even 1% but
we can't allow another dumb Middle East
war to get going and hopefully as a
combination of American elected
officials who are seeing this clearly
and maybe Iran recognizing this for the
delivery liberabit provocation that it
is we might be able to keep the United
States out of another one of these
endless and pointless military
engagements in the Middle East let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's sponsor is
Skillshare and I'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]